the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night past
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and again thank you guys
thank you for being part of this
community thank you for subscribing
supporting all of it whether you're new
here whether you've been here thank you
so much go watch my special Lefty son I
keep saying YouTube pulled it from the
algorithm it's still doing well so you
gotta go find it please go support that
share it like it comment all that good
stuff if you gotta have more then you
gotta check out the patreon listen to me
it's five bucks a month you get the
Honeydew a day early you get it ad free
you get it at no extra cost
and it's the wild I'm telling you it's
the best best deal on patreon it's five
bucks and you're hearing stories from
y'all okay we just had a lady who was
the victim of a murder-suicide attempt
her I believe it was husband at the time
shoots her she Ducks gets hit once in
the Carotid artery the other bullet Dr
Drew goes through her mouth out of her
cheek and neck she's now paralyzed in a
wheelchair her mom is in the house sees
this dude blows his brains out in front
of her and she runs out and plugs the
Carotid artery with her hand saves her
daughter's life five dollars y'all and
if you or someone you know has a story
it has to be told please submit it to
honeydew podcast gmail.com if you're
looking for a new podcast to listen to
go listen to my old podcast the crab
Feast it's one of the best just
storytelling podcasts out there
everybody you know and love in the
podcast land is on there Bill Burr
Christchurch Agora Christina P everybody
so uh go check that out subscribe to
that and this weekend I believe it's
this weekend July 7th and 8th Appleton
Wisconsin I'm gonna be there y'all get
your tickets for that August we got some
new dates to announce August 18th and
19th we're in Tampa September 1st and
2nd Springfield Missouri and September
15th and 16th Tulsa Oklahoma all right
that's all my back and lungs can handle
right now and uh that's the biz go get
your tickets at ryancicle.com now you
guys know what we do over here I always
say we highlight the low lights and
these are the stories behind the
storytellers I am very excited to have
this guest back on the Honeydew ladies
and Gentlemen please welcome Dr Drew
yeah buddy here we are young man so why
did YouTube put you in jail I want to
know more about that well they never
tell you they just say we have you can
call and get a person sometimes if you
if you're doing we have a contact who
also tells us she can't help us with
that and keeps pushing us off so I've
talked to nadav about theirs
it's they don't tell you they just say
we manually reviewed it and then my
question would be how many people one
person complained does one person decide
the fate of everything that goes out
there to all people what everybody else
can listen to right and then they give
you their bylaws like they give you
their algorithm and it says nothing you
you can look at it and go I didn't do
any of these rights right what are you
talking about so so disturbing also I
think the they don't like well this show
is I mean please subscribe this show and
help the show because the words on this
show and I'm gonna say them now so this
will be a demonetized episode but when
we talk about trauma and abuse and
molestation and rape those are words
allowed to talk about those are the
words that the algorithm doesn't like oh
my God we're demonetized in the queue
when Kirsten posted an Annie post an
episode on Sunday for a Tuesday release
it's already limited I don't know if
they're using AI to search words or what
it is of course my guess because how
could you possum we just uploaded
but it's literally the most significant
and common medical issues of our time
yeah
um I glorified weed in their opinion
which I mean I technically do over
alcohol I do I didn't glorify it in
general just comparing it to the one
thing
um and they don't like weed or marijuana
on YouTube at all it seems counter their
their culture even though it's legal
even though it's medicinal and blah blah
blah blah so something about weed though
you know I I have no problem with people
smoking we don't give a [__] but but
um we are seeing some stuff now because
you know concentration the
concentrations as you know are so
intense Oh you mean the power of these
things oh yes and so we are seeing
people that whose brains are can't
handle that yeah we're seeing psychosis
we're seeing mood disturbances we're
seeing anxiety disorders and we're
seeing addiction too particularly
getting onto the the uh dabs yeah if
you're doing that that you're in that I
don't even think my lungs could handle
it so it's really like it's crack it's
the crack of weed and I don't even do
the they also have infused ones where
they're taking the key for there and
then putting it back in I'm like yeah I
can't I just just give me some flowers
it's because people get tolerant they
need need more more and that's a problem
if you're getting into that sort of Zone
not that you know they're playing people
smoke weed every day are fine and I'm
not saying that at all but I'm saying we
got to get honest about given the
concentrations of THC that are in there
it is
you're not even old enough to remember
taking seeds seeds and sticks out of
those things
and put an album in front of me with one
on and I would sit there in an hour of
seeding my weed so I didn't get uh the
pops and the cracks and the sticks oh my
God they eat the seeds remember that
yeah my brothers used to chew them and
then we'd read things or hear things
that there were Sinai in them and stuff
is that is that real though I don't know
um look I wanted to talk to you about
this so this show is people coming on
and talking about the worst times of
their life if they're talking about
their trauma the things they've overcome
what I don't think we've ever really
discussed is actually what trauma is or
what it does to the imprinting of a
person especially at the age uh that it
happens I know like listening to again
I'm old listening to Loveline back in
the day when you guys would talk about
especially a young lady who had a voice
that was high pitched in her 40s or 50s
and I'm also I've smoked a lot of weed I
feel like there was a correlation to
about the time that trauma happened to
them maybe the age-ish am I sorta in the
ballpark so so one of the things that
trauma does is arrest development and we
started noticing that we would close our
eyes and listen to some of these voices
we we would immediately I could
literally picture the age of the Toronto
like like I'm talking to a six-year-old
that's what comes to mind if you're an
eight-year-old the voice would trigger
an image in my head of the age of that
individual I was spoken to speaking to
never wrong never he was never wrong and
there was another thing because just
because we were sitting there you know
with headphones listening all night uh
we also would get other kinds of
feelings from people if they had sort of
personality disorders from the dramas
because they would immediately we'd get
you know Adam would have a certain
reaction I'd have a reaction and that's
how things work I mean back in the
psychiatric hunt when I ran programs in
the psychiatric hospital we would sort
of uh confirm our diagnostic Impressions
based on
how people responded to the patients in
other words or how they responded to us
even in other words I had a nurse my
charge nurse uh loved sociopaths and if
she would say when the patient would
come in she'd just go I love him he's so
entertaining we just go oh [__] here we
go sociopath if the patient
we were never wrong and if the and if
the patient liked me like like a lot it
was a female borderline the borderline
is like me and my partner my physician
partner if they liked him bipolar
disorder all the bipolars like it was
just very interesting and so and so
that's why you have to have a team
because how we respond to other people
and how they respond to us is it's
protein it's all over the place and some
people don't like or don't respond to
others and so you have to have somebody
that you can reach them with so that was
that so then back to trauma
so trauma you know we really when you're
talking about trauma you're
there's there's adult trauma right being
in an earthquake or the military trauma
that kind of thing that results in all
sorts of symptomatology around PTSD and
anxiety disorders and sleep disturbances
and intrusive images and all the things
we know about the veterans struggle with
right that's that is a certain kind of
trauma that's an overwhelmingly
overwhelming experience in adulthood
if you've had earlier trauma those
overwhelming experiences in adulthood
tend to be more likely to trigger PTSD
so that's sort of adult trauma
it doesn't really affect your
personality development or anything like
that early trauma has a whole different
thing to it so really the trauma that
we're most concerned with is childhood
trauma right and we in this country have
lived through many years of massive
denial about what harms children I mean
there's now finally in the 90s they came
up with the adverse childhood
experiences the a scale what if you have
three or more of those experiences in
childhood that is sort of chronic trauma
that's you have a higher probability and
what percentage of people is that that's
very 90 let me tell you is there anyone
that goes there's no one that goes
unscathed though
they're boring if they do people are
very interesting when they've had
pathologies and things but but
um let me tell you some of the things
that are on the a scale and you'll see
how calm they are divorce
I mean Jesus Christ yeah a drug a drug
addict to the family a family member in
prison I mean you don't have to have
overt physical or sexual abuse of course
those are on the list too domestic abuse
not necessarily violence just fighting
in the parents so just add substance
uh divorce and fighting I would say
you're lucky if you only have three
that's right to be honest and when you
get five then you really are likely to
have very serious long-term problems
both medically and psychiatrically and
it's very common to have all and and
there are some that sort of obviously
are heavier so to speak are more likely
to impact and when you do have things
like physical and sexual abuse you
usually have some of the other things
going on as well so see I like talking
to you how old are you now Dr Drew 64.
God bless you good
um what are we planning here tonight
I noticed those guns as soon as you got
out of the car I was like look at you
you son of a [__] I you're You Got Me
by them 14 years but still I feel I
always say I'm part of the Walk It Off
generation like you go to your parents
back then it's like just walk it off
yeah yeah you know that little and by
the way we thought it was horrible and
abusive but it wasn't so bad relative to
what they were going on these days
you're right so I told you what's on my
mind today is I watched the Arnold
documentary on Netflix and uh he was
just like get busy do stuff do things
make a difference get involved just
gotta do things that your whole life
should be busy and you won't be so
disturbed by these things and he had a
physically abusive father alcoholic and
had all kinds of horrible [__] happen to
him and childhood too
but let's get back to what trauma is
so Trump I had to say this real quick
and this is why I wanted to ask you this
and I don't want to interrupt and I'll
shut up after well I don't want to drag
on back at the ymh days before pandemic
and all that good stuff happened
um
I had talked to you about uh my mother
and the physical mental emotional abuse
I suffered all that and you said
something interesting to me you said you
know if you're gonna because I maybe
even toyed with having her on an episode
or something you said it's interesting
but how old is she now and I said yeah
she's probably 70 or whatever and you
said it's you got to be careful with
something like that because at some
point when you see that old feeble
whatever person you end up looking like
yeah you're fully who's still attacking
this person feel bad and the funny thing
to me is like I've worked on it we have
a relationship now but up until I was 40
I could have said to you easily I could
live another 40 years and still be like
[__] you lady so that that imprinting in
every fiber of me from early on lives
underlying everything I do out there so
uh
forgiveness and owning it and all that
is really really important yeah but to
be interesting can we talk about how
something that young whatever your
trauma is yeah it all gets Everlasting
we'll get there yeah it's it's not well
I mean it's it has it it it leaves its
mark it doesn't have to but it's not
going to go on dude would you agree it's
not going anywhere especially or getting
any better if you don't work out oh boy
yeah no it I mean you know different
people have different ways I mean both I
I watched the documentary from both
Steven Spielberg and Arnold
Schwarzenegger and both of them talked
about how their work was their sort of
process and how they but they also
worked with therapists over there I'm
sure there's somebody did around them
and maybe they started they have people
around us and how we fit with them
changes you know who we are too so
anyway
um
so I had an abusive mom too emotionally
abusive unavailable all that kind of
stuff and um we towards the end of her
life she never came around never no and
in fact you know she was leaning on me
hard late in her life for on for medical
stuff and then what every time I'd offer
her an opinion she would fight with me
like abusively fight with me and finally
I go what what do you don't come to me
for this stuff if you're not she goes
just because I fight doesn't mean I'm
not gonna listen to you and I thought oh
this is this is perfect I just have to I
just have to bust your balls yeah
because that's what I do and I I finally
thought I I'm never gonna get anything
out of this relationship other than I
have to do what I need to do to be a
good son and that's it and and that's
how it ended I never got anything from
that relationship it's almost funny but
what was a good son in your eyes to to
answer her medical problems to show up
and visit regularly and to be available
to be there and not if I can you know
pop off any of this [__] when she
started firing at me and uh it's funny
uh she used to yell a lot and we
arranged a caretaker for her and I felt
Vindicated when this woman said to me
she she goes no you know it's great
we're gonna put the yelling the yelling
oh my God the yelling I thought imagine
you're three and that's going on how
long did it take you to get that
Vindication how many years
55. so some people die before they ever
get it you know what I mean some people
die yeah so trauma is diseases trauma is
essentially the experience of
at least psychically if not physically
the organism the person has a sense that
they will not go forward they will not
go on being it is a total Destruction
either of the Soul or the body like I'm
going I'm going to die or this
experience is just destroying me
psychically
and that experience of uh we're not set
up for that in childhood we don't we
don't we can't manage that if you're a
Navy SEAL you can manage that you're
trained to do it it still affects you
right you still have symptoms later down
the road
but as a child it literally shatters the
upper limit to the brain's regulatory
capacity and so the brain floods with
cortisol it shuts down the Vega system
the parasympathetic system kicks in
overdrive you have both hyper
stimulation because you're in sort of a
fight or flight and Hyper inhibition
because you can't go anywhere you're
stuck you're being abused and
hyperinhibition is probably what does
all the damage and in that state you
know our vagus nerve evolves with three
distinct nuclei and one of the nuclei is
linked into higher functions to as so it
has to kind of develop and it develops
as a key component of the brain's
regulatory system so the Vegas is turned
out is very embedded as we said in the
parasympathetic system and that happens
to be embedded also that vague those
vagal offshoots with the parasympathetic
input are are embedded in the what are
called the brain your pouches the
brachial pouches are what develop the
muscles to the ears vocal cords all the
facial musculature so when we feel
something we can literally attune our
ear to vocal porosity in the other we
can use vocal porosity to express
emotion ourselves and the tiny movements
of our facial muscles have deep
communication potential to particularly
children who may be pre-verbal for
instance that's how moms communicate
with babies with the tiniest input and
so
that system gets shattered it doesn't
develop the normal inputs to the higher
functions in the brain and it stays in
this sort of more primitive system of
dissociation and shutdown so
dissociation both from the feelings and
from your body also does dissociation
from the higher functions of the brain
so shut down dissociation either and
that dissociation Camp can't even be a
somata form dissociation so if what is
that so if the body is the source of the
misery the shattering physical abuse
sexual abuse
people will actually kind of dissociate
from their body and the body becomes a
source of disorganized information that
they never can regulate so oftentimes
get chronic pain and all kinds of
physical complaints that they can't
explain because they're disconnected
from the normal inflow of information
that gets regulated with the whole of
the brain
question so far
is it fit make sense yeah
so it begs the issue so that's this is
all work of a guy named Alan Shore and
Stephen porges uh Stephen poor just has
something called the poly Bagel Theory
where he talks about this
socio-emotional exchange system which is
the the vagal system that we we evolved
with as primates and humans in
particular
particularly to communicate with Mom
right that's really what early
pre-verbal communication but we retain
it the rest of our life all right my
question is this what what made
doctors science start studying this what
was what was the final Tipping Point
where they're like all right some shit's
going on in this these humans let's look
at this the the Kaiser adverse childhood
experience score was like in the 90s or
something maybe even the 2000s and you
know Adam and I were talking to
traumatized people every night it's
obvious when you work in general
medicine or in Psychiatry all the impact
of trauma that's always what you what
you see there was no agreement in the
medical community that had a thing I I
don't know even that late is not oh yeah
I think some of it is the history of
Psychiatry and some of it is the lack of
willingness to uh look at the social
what was really going on in our country
because we had all these divorces good
kids are little adults they're fine
they're just they look how resilient
they are they're out playing they seem
fine we just we were in massive massive
denial about this and the the Kaiser
study on a scores was really just some
somebody noticed that all these people
with all these medical problems also
seem to have this trauma I wonder if
childhood experiences impact on our
medical well-being later it seems to do
that but no thought of how it does it
right yet another thought the other
problem I think was you people don't
appreciate
there's a book out there called shrink
by a guy named Lieberman that Chronicles
this history very beautifully how much
American Psychiatry was captured by
psychoanalysis and psychoanalysis
minimize trauma in many and sort of
generally and Trauma was something sort
of imagined right do you imagined having
sex with your mother and you imagined
that somebody physically abused it's all
like it was going on and sometimes it is
let's be fair sometimes these are
distorted memory and false members
things like that how do you how do you
decipher that oh you can't it's it's
really possible it is because they
believe it so much they experience it
the selling of it is yeah I mean
oftentimes I deal with the parents these
people that have these Vivid experiences
that I have to sit and and process with
them because they're their experiences
and the parents just go I just didn't
happen I don't I
okay but you know I remember of all
things Maria bamford's mom saying some
of that stuff I heard her saying like
I'm real there's a lot of memories of me
and I'm um but maybe it did you know
maybe it's the mom's distorted memories
it doesn't matter and what matters is
the person has carries this with them
and you got to process it with them
so it begs the issue of how do you do
that and the the question let me just
finish my comment about Americans
psychoanalysis that that they just
didn't really want to deal with trauma
and is a separate thing they knew it was
there but they didn't know what it was
and they didn't have a full theory about
the impact and it was guys that
developed the the world of interpersonal
neurobiology developed like how brains
affect other brains and Alan Shore was
the sort of the he wrote a book called
affect regulation the origin of the self
and that was really the Breakthrough and
that's probably 30 years ago now
and he developed a whole bunch of
followers and people who did their own
research and developed their own stuff
and now there's a whole discipline in
that area and it and it just is bled
into everything even though a lot of
doctors don't really know it in the
detail I'm sharing with you guys they
understand that that's there we've
gotten away from the single skull notion
of psychology and psychiatry
the the central nervous system the the
brain the 90s was the decade of the
brain we moved on to that to realize oh
my God the brain is embedded in a body
and that body is actually the source of
feelings feelings of things that come
from the body we still don't know how
that really happens because we have
these huge nervous plexes you know
people call them what are the the
chakras but they're actually nervous
blocks in here we don't know what
they're doing they're like little mini
brains laying down in our body that
process information coming out of our
body and send it up through the vagus
nerve and if that vagus nerve is
disconnected from the higher function
then again you're not really hearing
your feelings you're not you know in
processing you know regulating feelings
it's that integrated system of brain
body we think of more now but of course
that brain body is embedded in
relationships those relationships are
embedded in a socio-historical context
so you see how these impacts you know
they they they're waves that's you know
spread out uh from the individual
experience and you have to think about
all other [__] especially in today's
world now
so it begs the issue
of how people uh develop uh emotional
regulation at all right and it turns out
uh brains heal other brains I think
we've known that for a long time right
but we'll sit with another person in
therapy and how that brain healed other
brains is something that really wasn't
that well understood until interpersonal
neurobiology came along and we start to
understand more now of how this this
thing of closeness of two brain bodies
uh communicate in ways that are well
beyond words and you know just just
experiences is something awesome about
the experience of two bodies in space
when the one body needs help and the
other body is willing to attune to that
and capable of attuning deeply to that
experience and the other person the
patient can tolerate the closeness most
people can't tolerate closeness when
they've uh been traumatized because the
closeness was the source of the trauma
the people they trusted oftentimes yeah
and so they just don't won't ever go
back I mean if they would go back they
could have sort of developed it with
their own family and friends and things
and sort of help process that but they
don't closeness is sort of a something
they have to manage rather than
something they experience and so they're
they're always sort of having
oftentimes whatever the manifestations
that resulted in their personality stuff
comes into the room in the relationships
whether it's projective identification
or manipulation or shutdown or lack of
uh ability to connect with feelings all
comes into the room with people's
therapy so we have to go back and look
at
what
humans were just meant to do to develop
emotion regulations so a guy named Peter
fonnegut figured that some of this stuff
out
and he has something called the
mentalization process and he studied
moms and babies and we can argue all day
about you know should it be where are
the dads coming into this the dads can
come into this at all we do we actually
do and of course some you know babies
don't have moms right they have Dads
Dads can do this uh we just don't do it
as automatically and if you've had
babies you'll not father nature it's
Mother Nature
we literally don't have the the big
corpus callosum that gives us the
connection to the right side of the
brain where all this is happening this
is why women are better people because
we literally well I used to say that I
used to say that and Adam gives me [__]
about that now because I don't know he's
angry at female politicians
so so I used to say that was a better
brain because it's more connected and
more internet but it comes with
liabilities like everything in humans uh
but but it
um
so it's a right brain phenomenon and we
can do it has been if you've ever been a
father you will notice you end up sort
of following behind your wife going how
did you know that how did you how do you
know he's hungry how do you know he's I
just I just know it I'm tuned I'm
attuned that right brain to right brain
communication before there's any verbal
so what is that made up of what is that
process made up of so
um when they observe this interaction
with babies of course there's eye
contact there's vocal porosity created
by the mom but mostly she does something
very interesting with her face
so the baby is approached by the mom and
the mom the babies then learn my mind
has content people can look at me and
understand me I have content
they're designed to look out into the
world first to phenomenon that is
totally contingent on them
so they are everything body function for
the first six months of life is all a
baby is attuned to they're not you
notice they don't make eye contact or
anything
in about six months today they shift to
partial contingencies things that are
sort of dependent on their behavior I
cry and people do things in response to
that I pull the cat's tail the cat does
something that mobiles I like hitting
mobiles and things seeing them do things
but the there is a huge part of our
brain that's dedicated to the face other
faces and we have this already this
interest in the social world we have the
Attunement of the mom who's always in
our face making eye contact exchanging
with us and that is very satisfying to
the baby
and what that exchange is made up of is
the child has an experience has an
emotion
uh and the mom approaches studies like a
Tunes like what is going on here what
does my body tell me this body is
experiencing and she'll arrive at
something with a right brain message
that comes over to the left side uh via
her vagus nerve and she will
automatically on her face show
a representation of what the child is
experiencing it will sometimes be with
the subtle eye musculature or the
corners of the mouth it's not something
you would necessarily even notice as an
adult but the child is very interested
if you've ever been in deep therapy I'll
tell you when I was in deep therapy and
I noticed I felt started feeling bad for
my therapist because I was so I mean her
face I was I was aware of every every
muscle and I thought this poor woman I
said yes she can't smile who I can't
even like without me like in on it and I
thought well there's that exchange thing
again
um
so the child learns that that
representation is a second order
representation of their feeling like
somebody understands my feeling and
they're showing it back to me I don't
have I don't have words yet I don't have
verb I don't have language it's
pre-language stuff this all starts and
so that's my feeling and then the mother
offers alongside that feeling vocal
porosity soothing affects and in that
exchange of body to body helps the baby
then regulate that feeling it's it's not
so scary because Mom understands it in
other adult experiences it with me and
we we co-regulated of course the babies
hip us their their eye movements are our
pupils normally do this I'm moving my
fingers up and down uh and and the baby
and the mom's hippest times together as
well as their heart rates and all these
things it's profound the the way our
bodies attuned as particularly as
caretakers of children especially women
um or whatever we're calling these
biological entities that they're able to
do this now I don't know right yeah
um so so there it is that's the exchange
that's the fundamental aspect of the
change the exchange this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp sometimes in
life we are faced with tough choices in
the path forward isn't always clear
whether you're dealing with decisions
around your career relationships or
anything else therapy helps you stay
connected to what you really want while
you navigate life so you can move
forward with confidence and excitement
you know this is a mental health show
right and we preach therapy on this show
so if you're thinking about it and it's
something you haven't tried yet
try it if it's something you're looking
to get back into try it all right if
you're thinking of starting therapy at
all give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com honeydew today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew
betterhelp.com honeydew now let's get
back to the do you mentioned deep
therapy so I want to talk about this for
a second because you introduced me to
EMDR therapy which incorrectly for a
while called edmr therapy
um and I've passed that gift on to so
many people in my personal life and I'd
preach it on here because I have never
I've I don't even know it was called
Talk therapy until I was introduced to
EMDR there but I'm like oh this is just
me talking to someone and like you say
brain to brain getting some insight some
hindsight whatever it is
um but this EMDR therapy man I I
originally had gone for uh my daughter
almost got hit by a car and all of a
sudden I became terrified to fly yeah
and and amdi is perfect for stuff like
that a little ridiculously
um uh scared of heights all of a sudden
not not you know when I'm in a plane I
look out the window that looks like a
cartoon classic dude 200 Classic 300
feet
and within
I mean two months eight sessions maybe
yeah I was done I can sleep on my
flights now now I look at other people
when turbulence hits and they're like oh
and I just like man but you may want to
go deeper again to deal with some of the
childhood stuff too because that can be
managed the same way I don't know if you
did do a lot of stuff but we got the sum
of it but my main focus was like let's
get me I need to fly to work yeah I get
it no no it's perfect for that and and I
it worked and I was doing therapy back
before EMDR was sort of a standard kind
of way of doing this it it really gets
your brain when it's been traumatized
right
I've described you know how the Vegas
thing is sort of set up uh when it
dissociates right from trauma you're
shut down your body just so all these
things dissociate it leaves that part of
the brain disconnected wiring Wise from
the the regulation of the hole it's just
a piece that's often the distance there
and the individual experience that it's
it's adaptive it's a survival thing that
the human brain does but the experience
the individual experience that is well
that's I don't think about that anymore
that's done
it isn't done with you it's in the
background they're always needing it's a
part of you and it needs attention
that [__] was laying in the Panic just
waiting
like you said at age 55 you felt
Vindicated that no that popped up for I
loved flying if I felt like a rock star
taking off in this guy then all of a
sudden I was like and I was like how
what is going on and I couldn't get over
that it worked like let's talk about the
the buzzing in the hands and just sort
of what it does to your literally does
to your brain we literally don't really
know
that's the thing it was all been
discovered very serendipitously
there was a woman walking through the
forest and noticed when she moved right
back and forth she was able to she
started experiencing things she'd been
trying to get at for a long time and
couldn't get to and all of a sudden
there it was and so it it does it it's I
think of it as kind of a releasing like
a frontal releasing uh experience like
they're they're repetitive things you
can do that tend to kind of slow down or
shut down parts of the brain that get in
the way of us experiencing things the
defensive structure or cognitive
structure all that stuff gets in the way
uh and when you do EMDR all that kind of
slows up or shuts down and what comes up
is what's been sitting there needing
some attention for quite some time
typically and uh it will cause people to
do behaviors and do drugs and all kinds
of things is that right even later in
life like that oh my God yes that's why
people say I I feel comfortable for the
first time they didn't even realize they
were uncomfortable but that part has
been there driving stirring things up
and it's often it if you've had you know
bad abuse it's often pain it's really a
feeling of pain all the time that you're
walking around in the background with
don't even know
so so the I want to go back to the the
baby and the exchange let me see it if I
finish that so so if you've been uh
traumatized particularly by the person
or the people that are supposed to be
the source of the regulation
that is such a a violation of trust it
is so shattering that you can't trust
anybody after that so trust becomes a
major issue closeness becomes a major
issue and think about how vulnerable
children are you know that think about
they they're open and vulnerable they
just right they're just there and then
all of a sudden you can tell them
anything Santa Claus this happens and it
just they can't it shatters their
ability to tolerate and they will not
come back that's it's it's no go anymore
and that's what you're trying to
overcome that's what I deal with in the
addiction field all the time trying to
get them into the frame of just being
able to rebuild that regulatory system
why does it lead us to things like
addiction though why because you're in
pain and these things are you don't
realize it and all of a sudden you feel
okay you tell a 17 year old or 15 year
old who just felt good for the first
time in his or her life and been
carrying a lot of pain around or isn't
aware of it
it's hard to get them not to do those
things and then if you have the genetic
potential for addiction well now then
that kicks in so you have two problems
you're trying to regulate trauma and you
have addiction which is a common
combination yeah
and what do you think let's talk about
men especially because it's a this is a
generation I feel like I always say
we're we're an interesting generation of
men because my grandfather was World War
II my father was Vietnam era and then
I'm like I want to be a clown you know
what I mean it's like what the [__] are
you talking about you know what I mean
so we're a weird sort of generation of
men who also are trying to stop this
this TR train of trauma moving on and
really sort of uh Frankie keones who was
on here called our parents professional
suppressors and I was like it's a great
term they just pushed everything down
yeah and now we're trying to figure out
what the hell's going on to stop these
cycles and all that correct but I don't
think enough men are comfortable enough
to still sit and talk about mental
health and what they're going through I
think it's still a lot of that machismo
[__] like I'm I'll walk it off I'm
fine well remember we're wired for that
I mean that's how the brain that's what
the brain wants us to do just forget
about it move on and survive survive is
that men or anyone anyone but men have a
little more of that because we're not
connected to that part of our brain very
well
the corpus callosum is smaller
so you know
it's a pendulum always right I mean when
you look back at some of the parenting
we had some of that now starts to look
good compared to the helicopter I agree
with that and the his office team
[__] that we did a generation a
disservice trying to undo what we
thought our parents had done the uh
everyone gets a trophy generation that's
terrible I mean I had kids late but that
is basically the people I went to high
school with is that's their generation
terrible really and being perfect
parents because our parents were so
shitty we're I'm not gonna do that to my
kid and kids need adversity they need
challenges they they have to come up
against reality that's what mental
health is is managing reality on
reality's terms yeah they don't need
abuse yes they need more emotional
openness but they do need a certain
amount if I can get on with it and just
go go try out the football team if you
fail try harder right not because you
need to deserve a trophy you're the best
let me go tell that coach something
because coach
get your [__] together all right watch
that Arnold documentary everybody but it
is it is all about this just go do stuff
guy the guy was dedicated to you know
Improvement uh and so
yeah I think now we've done another
disservice to another population by
overdoing our sort of involvement and
engagement and sacrifice for kids uh
it's because it's our own vulnerability
our own feeling of pain that we are
trying to avoid in them but that's our
pain not theirs right we can't make them
responsible for that so as always the
pendulum goes back and forth it's never
a perfect parent it just doesn't exist I
I would argue that we have moved forward
in terms of uh our ability to manage you
know really significant things and
understanding significant things as it
pertains to the impact of parenting on
human development we're kind of getting
better at all that
but damn
take a bunch of nine-year-olds and tell
them
they have to hide under their bed
shelter in place and if you go outside
you're going to kill your parents and
your grandparents and oh by the way no
contact with your peers for two years or
if you do you a Michelle a swab up your
nose and here's school on this pad oh
the porn don't pay attention to that
what the [__] did we think we were gonna
end up with I mean it was just it was so
predictable I kept saying we're gonna
we're gonna destroy eight to 15 year
olds and we did
so the mental health stuff there is just
intense now and it is huh oh my God but
in your field are you seeing at least
more and more in particular men coming
forward to talk about things and and
yeah I mean and also what race of people
do you see least in therapy
two questions do the tell me about me so
I'm not working so much in day-and-out
mental health I'm doing general medicine
now so so I'm going to speak sort of
generally and great great great generic
numbers yeah I know
what do you call it uh where you
generalize about people yeah
um what was that last thing you said
what race of people before that you said
something else are you seeing more men
these days come forward I think men have
benefited from the zoom revolution in
health okay
because we don't want to run to somebody
in the waiting room there's no waiting
room we don't want to turn our camera on
don't [__] turn your camera on that's
fine uh you know we got to get them in
the door you can remain anonymous you
can do whatever you want just get in the
door and that is a lot of the struggles
getting them in and of course men with
all medical stuff you are more likely to
come in because their female partner
brought them in then I mean that's
that's how I get my prostate cancer
diagnosis my mom my wife was like if I
get I'm making you an appointment all
right boom prostate cancer and uh you
know that's and that's definitely my
experience in practicing out there it's
the men particularly younger you know
like middle-aged man we don't want to
come
uh if we die we die we'll find out soon
enough if this is a bad problem so we're
so daddy we're so stupid uh
so all right so what race
uh
uh sure I can really generalize
I would say of course I would say it's
more about
well there are definitely cultures okay
like certain certain Asian cultures are
about you know don't it's actually
anathema to share your feelings you just
keep it shut down uh so certainly that
culture Bears out many times on people's
ability to come in and share and do the
work of treatment
um in my experience the African-American
Community uh has well reasonably has had
a horrible experience with mental health
in this country uh and so doesn't trust
it all and if they have trauma now
they're doubly not trusting it and I I I
say that's not only is that healthy
that's real that's reality yeah uh but
we have lots of African-American
practitioners now and people that are
culturally trained and they should open
up they'd rather go to the church
and people do go there and I I think the
church is slowly moving towards
understanding they got to refer back I
mean generally and plenty of white
people do that too trust me the churches
is a reasonable place to go for certain
kinds of spiritual experiences and
oftentimes they'll have people train
there that will help them more with the
mental health piece and I've seen more
and more they're more willing to refer
back to when it's outside of their
ability so that that exchange is
starting to happen which is good
uh
I I worry about the lack of
acknowledgment of uh trauma and
intergenerate you know trauma transmits
intergenerationally yeah let's talk
about that yeah is it it really does is
it uh is it in our is it in our DNA yeah
I don't we don't there are people that
theorize that that's an epigenetic
phenomenon of course intense experiences
we do know does affect our genes whether
that can be passed epigenetically I'm
not I'm not sold uh you don't need that
to pass trauma all you need is somebody
who is physically abused for instance
and felt that that was something they
needed for discipline and then they do
it to their children that's it it's it's
on it's on then and this it's the odd
thing about trauma there's some several
odd things about trauma one is we we uh
not just normalize it but we make it
good right that's a way of sort of
feeling okay as opposed to feeling like
I was nearly destroyed by this and I'm a
little thing I'm a little being that was
so dependent on this big person and that
person nearly destroyed me we identify
with the perpetrator and say they're
doing what's right for me I needed this
and therefore I'm gonna be that big
person and do that for my children oh
man is that [__] up thinking that is
the exact opposite of of how we should
go in our in our brains and yet we do it
that way the other thing we do uh the
odd thing that humans do is that we
recreate the traumas of the past
when when their childhood traumas in
particular so Dad is an abusive
alcoholic who a band as the family you
imagine you are automatically are
attracted to abuse of alcoholic men if
you're a daughter of that guy and you do
it over and over and over again of
course because if you're attractive to
some guy's an abusive abandoning
alcoholic he will oblige you and be an
abusive abandoning alcoholic that's what
he does and yet you do it again and even
when you know I hear uh people saying
this all the time I am never going to be
around a guy or a woman like that again
the men are often more than the
codependent size I know I got it I see
what they are I know it now I'm never
going to do that again here's the
extraordinary thing they always do it
again
because no one talks about attraction
they talk about you learned your lesson
cognitively which they have but they're
still attracted to those kinds of people
and even though cognitively that doesn't
person seems not to have all those
features and I'm not going to be around
anymore the fact that I'm attracted to
that person tells you it's that kind of
person again unless you you either have
to one of two things when you're in that
pattern of repetition you have to either
not go for people you're so attracted to
so we tell people think butterflies not
lightning bolts if it's a lightning
bolts attraction it's going to be the
abuse of banning alcohol again even
though it doesn't look like that it's
gonna be that I promise you it's you
you're a perfect instrument you're
having lightning bolts so if you can
find somebody who maybe is recovering
alcoholic or maybe shared had an
alcoholic parent also and shares that
with you and you're sort of attracted
but not lightning bolts and you can
build a closeness there you'll find it
much more satisfying
you can't do that you got to go to
therapy or you will keep doing the same
damn thing so let me ask you this then
how do we especially as parents
um if we do need to correct some but not
too much what's the balance of not over
correcting and not being the helicopter
everybody gets a trophy
I I don't know because I don't know I'm
the same way like my daughter gets a
participation trophy I'm like no the the
award or excuse me the reward is the is
participating yeah okay we can't how the
hell does anybody know what bad is if we
don't know what good is this team also
over here they did better than everybody
else this year these coaches these kids
these parents whatever it was whatever
cohesive thing they had going on there's
going to be one they did it better than
everybody else yeah what the hell does
the Owen 12 team get the Trope my
stepson used to get trophies like I'm
not kidding you come up to us I'm like
and they'd be broken in his room and
stuff I had my trophies
until I was in my 30s and I did a photo
shoot with them and then I just sent
them off to the dumpster but I will tell
you the one thing that we had back in
those days that they got rid of that I
thought was very meaningful most
improved
remember that most of foods had the same
status as most valuable yeah because the
guy or gal that really put in the effort
and it was shitty to begin with and
really started to perform with the team
that was awesome I got most improved
when you're choking up really it's weird
uh and it was the and it was the most
important thing ever happened to me uh
and I thought an acknowledgment for
having gone from a benchwarmer to a
player was a big deal to me and that was
overcoming adversity which is what we
all need these experiences doing we need
to be challenged with stuff and we we
can be present for our kids so here's
the balance be present for your kids as
a refueling station but do not co-sign
any of their stuff do not rescue them
from anything we rescue in this in this
uh parent group yeah
rescuing is I see the pain in the child
I have to make it stop okay why do you
need to make it stop I mean I understand
you want to go help a child but the
reason you have to make it stop is your
pain was mobilized the pain left behind
from your childhood you don't realize
the distinction between that child's
pain and your pain and your pain is
mobilized it's a very deep psychological
experience that most people can't
differentiate so most of what I worked
with in therapy myself does it work the
other way where like I've seen my DOT
like she had a dance recital okay
Saturday was rehearsal
we're leaving the rehearsal she's in her
little dress and tights and she's got
Crocs on and she's doing a balance beam
on the curb
and I hear [__] and I look back on the
ground tights knee ripped knees bleeding
and I saw her look at me with the Panic
it wasn't even about the knee ripped it
was holy [__] these tights are ripped
recitals tomorrow we don't have any and
I felt the panic and I said hey you're
good she's like oh my knee and I'm like
I grew up very boy you know it was beat
my brothers were constantly wrecking
bikes no helmets you know idiot [__]
back then but when I see my daughter's
knee and she's going oh I'm the other
way with it I'm like it's a scrape well
not only that but now let's go back to
the Early Childhood exchange so the
child comes up to the mom
and I hurt my finger and the mom goes oh
my God oh my God I need a drink you make
me crazy I can't you know I need a drink
that child then is not you need a bandit
right so so that child learns that when
I have a feeling my mom catches the
feeling and evokes something that I
don't want right that's where
codependency comes from so now I have to
I can't show her my feelings I have to
suppress my feelings to manage her
feelings make sure she doesn't go get
loaded again or to make sure she doesn't
yell at me again and that's that's not
good what the child needs is you to be
present not feel their feelings but
appreciate their feelings which is a
different thing that's what I try to do
to try to say I know I know that if
you're feeling very evoked that you have
a feeling that is the opposite of what
the child needs right you get that and
so this is what boundaries are about
a boundaries right and so is our
generation of Paris generally yeah and
that's where the rescuing kicks in we
have to because our boundaries are
shitty and we evoke these things that we
should be just being with and just
differentiating my feelings from your
feelings
we're not we are evoked and we have to
rescue and that keeps a child ever in
need of rescue now let's say you've been
pretty good at those boundaries a lot of
the children's life and you've been
letting them be challenged and letting
them fall down and stuff
there is still I've noticed something
about our parenting style that they
these kids even at a young adulthood say
remain awfully preoccupied with us in
our day the parents we wanted to get the
[__] away as fast as possible and just
get the hell out of here I can't stand
to be around these people on my bike I'm
going to play anything but then as soon
as you're 18 you're like that's it man
I'm never coming back I may be around
them a little bit but I I'm not gonna
stay here the bouncing back stuff is is
us that's us that's why kids are still
20 well let we can get into how
expensive but I don't even right it's
all there's a legitimate piece they're
bouncing back that's especially in
California it's impossible it's insane
and so and humans have lived in
multi-family General in households
forever so maybe this is a little okay
thing maybe this isn't a good thing and
our desire to get out because a man at
17. I left for college at 17. that was
it I couldn't even imagine I I couldn't
but I was raised in an extended family
like my grandmom was like a mom and I I
feel like what that really did today I
still have a very
um if I see an elderly lady especially
or someone I'm right over there to help
him out like I I try to do things like
that where my grandmom would be proud
you know what I mean but also I got to
learn what I'm living with this lady
who's it's my father who died but that's
her son and more and more now I start to
see and feel what she possibly could
have felt you know like I'm over there
going Grandma let Dad rest in peace you
know what I mean like it's always you're
crying about him whatever and now I'm
like apparent I couldn't even imagine
you know and I she would say I'm never
gonna see him come up that hill again
and I think of those lines have stuck
with me and I replay them what 30 years
later as a parent now that I didn't even
remember I remembered that damn thing
and I'm like God you're you lost the sun
I lost a dad they're both devastating
but
I don't know which one's worse the one
thing no it's the parent be in this in
these are losing the child because let
me just say this yeah is that when your
parents have been abusive and never
really fully healed that they do you a
favor at the end of their life because
you're like it's okay I I see people
with they were very close say they're
like the mom thing for you and I very
close to their moms who just suffer for
forever they lost their mom and I'm like
I didn't I didn't have I got one yeah
thank you Mom I don't really have any
deep feelings about it because there was
nothing there
you know
50 years of destroying a child's Bond
well done
yeah you succeeded yeah you succeeded
so I'm more attached to my therapist my
wife and my daughter yeah that way so I
you know I I it's interesting because my
daughter knows my mom as her Grandmom to
be a good grandma Yeah at some point
someday she'll listen to these episodes
and hear the relationship we had yeah
and I don't know what's gonna happen
when that happens and I'll address it
you know honestly
um
because the relationship she has with
her grandmother is not the relationship
I have it's one of the things I was
struggling with when we tried to
reconnect I'm like is there relationship
my business so so you've mentioned now
connection I said attachment or attach
and I'm I'm I misspoke a little bit when
I say yeah you asked where the trauma
understanding came from
it really came out of attachment stuff
attachment Theory and what was noticed
there was um some famous theoreticians
back in 40 50 years ago who came up with
adult attachment Styles they're four
different attachment Styles let's hear
this well there's insecure there's just
organized there's avoidant there's
secure healthy I was gonna say or
anything yeah but it's rare you don't
see it that much anymore but in therapy
people re-establish secure attachment
with people that's what sort of happens
and each of these has its own sort of
style to it and and it they the original
researcher was like well how does this
happen what's going on in people's
brains and that's how they got to all
the stuff I've been talking about today
and attachment is another system
operating in the brain it's sort of a
way of navigating closeness let's say
that uh and you know there's there is
um
you know closeness and Regulation and
Attunement there is attachment and
there's love and each of these are very
their own little system and we don't
have a lot of understanding on on the
two we had we got to the regulation part
because that I think we got there quick
because it had therapeutic value but uh
and an attachment does have there are
people trying to categorize what's going
over on the regulation side with the
attachment stuff and that's that's and
then love is its own kind of bird uh
it's over here and then there's Spirit
too which is another kind of
right sort of sort of hard to go onto
the microscope stuff uh and I love that
stuff it's meaningful it's real but it's
it's
um
it's it's something that people
experience in different ways and but
it's all though
love and Attunement and attachment and
it's all about
me with you
this thing we call relationship
and and that is where I experience the
spiritual
yeah I um you know at first when my
daughter's mother and I split I was just
so worried about the back and the fourth
and we say you know kids are resilient
all that and I don't know there are
times where I wonder if going back and
forth isn't actually good for her to see
maybe different parenting style
different lifestyle over here these
people in this world these neighbors
this whatever versus
a little more dude do you think that
could be a little more helpful in sort
of like being well-rounded yeah I don't
want to use words like more and helpful
fair enough but but there might be
something to it provided that it may
give more breadth to her understanding
of herself and her experience whether
it's more better helpful I'm not sure
but it it certainly has that potential
to give more breath
the problem is there's something called
splitting you know what splitting is
okay splitting is a problem in parenting
and it's a problem in personality
development
which is what children naturally do
which is Mommy I want an ice cream no
it's an hour before dinner no
daddy mommy mommy's daddy I want ice
cream dad says all right sure getting
ice cream Mommy Dad said I can get this
is splitting this and when people when
uh humans children especially and adults
too to some extent can pit one person
against another they often feel split
internally there's no consistent hole in
themselves because there's this
relationship and there's this
relationship over here and I split the
two of them so I don't get the hole that
I need so that's what you got to watch
out for all right yeah the splitting and
if she starts splitting you guys you
know it's on yeah now it's on Daddy I
have way more fun over here with you
mommy's such a [__]
and and again back to my I hear that's
coming in the teens oh yeah oh yeah yeah
oh we'll have another conversation then
um but that's why I I was we started
this conversation talking about my team
that I built to to treat drug addicts
alcoholics that's another thing the team
has to be has to be unsplittable we have
to know each other so well that when
they go and said Dr Blum said Dr pinskin
out of Blum said I can have that Xanax I
just go no he didn't no he didn't I know
I know him I know we just just go back
get back to the group just shut up right
you know and we are a unified without
exception no one ever doubts what the
other person is judgment is and we just
know each other and how we how we
respond yeah that's great yeah Dr Drew
thank you so much for coming on here
it's great I hope that people use this
as a bit of a
it's kind of like a resource yeah this
is a different podcast yeah I know it's
in the comedy world but we do really sit
down and talk about real things yeah and
this what I what I feel like we really
um
ran the cycle you know they really
covered this topic so people want to
visit this topic you know revisit this
pod listen to this thing because there's
a lot of material in here I was going
over very quickly I don't expect anyone
to kind of get it all at once but this
is sort of I'm going to be re-listening
this is sort of the there are books out
there on this you know people that try
to write books you know help people
understand these things but this was a
pretty good synopsis of of the landscape
of this topic so hell yeah thank you
very much um plug promote everything
please so go to doctor.tv please uh my
wife does a streaming show Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday at three o'clock
where we have been interviewing all the
doctors and uh scientists who have been
canceled during covet and you will learn
a [__] ton all right I've learned so
much I don't agree with everything they
say I have some of some of the stuff I
understand why they're gonna cancel but
they all they all they all have stuff in
there like well hell you were there when
this happened oh my God it had what were
they think oh whoa I am so it's I'm the
whole pandemic I was just sitting there
going what is going on
that is what I'm slowly answering is
what happened how did this this
incredibly missed obvious misadventure
happened to us and what are the
consequences going to be
and then also after dark which you've
been on several times over at your mom's
house Doctor Drew after dark and I do a
podcast with Adam on a regular basis
still Adam Carolla and the doctor
podcast all at Dr drew.com thank you Dr
Drew uh as always Ryan sickler.com Ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
please